The Russo Brothers are back at it again.
In the days leading up to their appearance
at this year's San Diego Comic-Con, which
takes place from July 18 to July 21, Avengers:
Infinity War and Avengers: Endgame directors
Joe and Anthony Russo have taken to social
media to tease what they'll be showing off
at the highly anticipated entertainment convention.
What started off simply has turned into something
much bigger, and fans are going absolutely
bonkers over the Russos' most recent tease.
Things began innocently when the sibling filmmakers
shared an Instagram photo of the San Diego
Comic-Con logo as a way to confirm that they'd
be presenting their own panel "A Conversation
with the Russo Brothers," which will be held
on Friday, July 19 at 11 AM PST.
Then, the teasing evolved when the Russo Brothers
shared a video with text that read "07/19/19"
and background audio from 2017's San Diego
Comic-Con, where a snippet of Avengers: Infinity
War played out for the attendees in Hall H.
"There is no way in hell that we are not gonna
show you some footage."
Naturally, Marvelites began speculating that
the Russos' panel could include some exclusive
footage from past Marvel movies.
That theory changed when the directing duo
posted another video of audio from Community,
the sitcom they executive produced in the
years before they became MCU icons.
"Donde, está, la biblioteca.
Me llamo T-Bone, la araña discoteca."
Fans' minds began racing a mile a minute,
then went into overdrive with the Russo Brothers'
third and most recent SDCC tease: a video
containing audio from Arrested Development,
yet another television series the two worked
on pre-Marvel.
In the video, Jeffrey Tambor's character delivers
his iconic mini-monologue:
"How much clearer can I say?
There's always money in the banana stand!”
Some fans are of the opinion that the Russos
might confirm that a Community film is in
the works, while others believe that they'll
announce season 6 of Arrested Development.
Still, others believe that they'll offer an
update on the Arrested Development movie that's
been coming together since 2009.
One fan pointed out that the Russos definitely
have the money to fund a Community movie,
an Arrested Development film, or both.
They might even be using their earnings from
Avengers: Endgame, which has grossed over
$2.78 billion worldwide as of July 16, to
revisit their old works.
Any way you toss it, fans are flipping over
the Russo Brothers' pre-San Diego Comic-Con
teases.
But there truly is no telling exactly what
they have planned for their convention panel.
All we know is that Collider's editor-in-chief
Steve Weintraub is moderating the presentation,
which is officially billed as being a reflection
of the Russos' time filming Avengers: Endgame
and a look into how they will transition into
"life beyond Marvel" with their production
company AGBO.
There's a chance that AGBO could be the studio
behind a Community movie or an Arrested Development
film, and that when the panel discussion shifts
to AGBO, the Russos will unveil one or both
of those projects.
What likely won't be featured during "A Conversation
with the Russo Brothers" is any talk of Marvel's
Phase 4 plans, since that will presumably
be reserved for Marvel Studios' Hall H panel
on Saturday, July 20 at 5:15 PM PST.
The notoriously secretive studio hasn't confirmed
anything about its film schedule past Spider-Man:
Far From Home, the Phase 3-ender that swung
into theaters at the start of July.
A handful of movies notably The Eternals and
the Black Widow solo film have already begun
taking shape.
But Marvel is essentially pretending that
they don't exist for the time being.
Whatever happens at the Russos' personal panel,
it probably won't be MCU-related.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.